يعني انت تعترض على فكره ناصر ابو زيد
اوكي حوريه الرقم مقفوله جيب كتاب مفهوم
النص تعطيل البحث يعمل دكتوراه طب خذ
القراءه وحاول تكتب عناصر عشان تنقذه لا
يستطيع اللغه مفقوده باللغه التراثيه
قديمه وباللغه كتابيه حديثه فاصبح التواصل
مش موجود طب انت بتنقض ده ازاي وانت ما
انتاش فاهم هو بيقول ايه وده اللي نرجع
للحاله تفضلت به للشيخ محمد عبده الشيخ
محمد عبده قامت عليه ضجه لانه الشيخ محمد
عبده فاهم ان العالم لابد ان يقوم بواجب
الوقت واجب الوقت ايه كما قلت انك انت
تفهم المجتمع وكيف تخاطب الناس بالاسلام
الناس عقول متغيره والفقهان من قديم قالوا
تتغير الاحكام بتغير الزمان والمكان
والاشخاص والاحوال يعني هناك مثلا احكام
قد تناسب بلدا لا تناسب ايضا اخر هناك
ظروف الامام الشافعي لما ترك العراق وجاء
الى مصر تبدلت عنده بعض الاحكام وبعض
الرؤى والاجتهادات لان في الاحكام
المتغيره لانه وجد المجتمع هنا غير
المجتمع في العراق